and that's funny besides that again I'll
be entrusted to the horns window not me
time to go pure evil on this one some of
it could be once you have decks are
adorned oh yeah I'm filled here's the
deal when you learn a new character
especially our game in injustice -
sometimes like to trace the last thing
you really start optimizing quite well
you can wake up now he's in the corner
oh no
okay I'll do that
yep hear that again
throwing coins that that's right I'm
rich I really just want to work it seems
like a bad strategy
yeah but would be really awesome if I
nail it yes we haven't got something to
change right I can say worse than a car
but there could be children watching
hope we've we've branched out to like
okay it's team man just throwing out
that's fun
that is fun where's that face look
amazing I think that's like a sultan
figure that is such a selfie oh yeah
that's home afterwards
we got eight seconds left I think she
have to walk back and sit around oh you
got the first Lantern that's great
congratulations gosh